ANDERSON.
AND THIS HOUR, DEPORTED FOR
BEING A UIGHUR.
IN CHINA'S SHIN ZEN REGION, UP
TO 2 MILLION UIGHURS HAVE BEEN
DETAINED IN VAST GOVERNMENT
CAMPS AND THEY CONTINUE TO FACE
WHAT THE U.S. HAS CALLED A
GENOCIDE.
BEIJING DENIES THE ALLEGATIONS,
DISMISSES THEM AS PROPAGANDA AND
SAYS THE CAMPS ARE VOCATIONAL
TRAINING CENTERS FOR COMBATING
RELIGIOUS EXTREMISM.
SOME UIGHURS HAVE MANAGED TO
LEAVE CHINA BUT SOME EVEN ABROAD
SAY THEY'RE NOT SAFE.
THE NEW HUMAN RIGHTS WATCH
REPORT SAYS CHINA HAS TRACKED
DOWN HUNDREDS OF UIGHURS ACROSS
THE GLOBE FORCING THEM TO RETURN
AND FACE PERSECUTION.
FROM KAZAKHSTAN TO AUSTRALIA TO
NOW ON THE GROUND IN XINJIANG
ITSELF, CNN HAS BEEN LOCATING
FAMILIES WHO HAVE BEEN SEPARATED
AFTER LOVED ONES WERE DETAINED.
NOW A CNN INVESTIGATION DIVES
INTO UIGHUR DEPORTATIONS FROM
THE MIDDLE EAST, A STINGING
BETRAYAL BY PREDOMINANTLY MUSLIM
COUNTRIES.
JOMANA KARADCHEH HAS MORE.
>> Reporter: THIS PROTEST
OUTSIDE ISTANBUL'S CONSULATE IS
A RACE AGAINST TIME.
NORIMAN'S FATHER'S FATE HANGS IN
THE BALANCE.
IF HE'S SENT BACK TO CHINA,
HE'LL BE IMPRISONED, AND THERE'S
DANGER OF DEATH, SHE TELLS US.
SHE AND HER SISTER LOST CONTACT
WITH THEIR MOTHER IN CHINA'S
XINJIANG REGION FOUR YEARS AGO.
IF GOD FORBID WE LOSE OUR FATHER
AS WELL, IT WILL DESTROY US, SHE
SAYS.
HER FATHER, A UIGHUR MUSLIM
SCHOLAR, WAS NABBED BY SAUDI
AUTHORITIES IN NOVEMBER WHILE ON
A PILGRIMAGE TO ISLAM'S HOLIEST
CITY.
SHE PLEADS, SEND HIM BACK TO
TURN
TURKEY WHERE HE'S A RESIDENT,
NOT CHINA.
FOR HER FATHER, THERE IS STILL
TIME.
FOR OTHEROTHERS, THERE IS LITTL
HOPE.
WE SPOKE TO TWO OF THE FAMILIES
WHO CONFIRMED THE DEPORTATIONS.
THIS IS JUST ONE PART OF WHAT
APPEARS TO BE A TERRIFYING
CAMPAIGN BY CHINA.
OVER THE COURSE OF OUR
INVESTIGATION, WE HAVE ALSO
FOUND CASES OF UIGHURS FORCIBLY
RETURNED TO CHINA FROM THE
UNITED ARAB EMIRATES AND EGYPT.
IN VIOLATION OF INTERNATIONAL
LAW AND WHERE THEY MAY FACE WHAT
THE U.S. HAS LABELED A GENOCIDE.
SAUDI ARABIA, THE UAE AND EGYPT
DID NOT RESPOND TO OUR REQUEST
FOR COMMENT.
CHINA'S A MAJOR TRADE PARTNER TO
THE MUSLIM MAJORITY COUNTRIES
WHO HAVE NOT ONLY TURNED A BLIND
EYE TO CHINA'S TREATMENT OF
UIGHURS.
THEIR AUTOCRATIC GOVERNMENTS
HAVE ALSO VOICED SUPPORT FOR
WHAT CHINA INSISTS IS A
COUNTERTERRORISM CAMPAIGN.
MIRIAM MUHAMMAD HAS BEEN KEEPING
A DARK SECRET FROM HER BOYS,
TRYING TO SHIELD THEM FROM THE
CRUEL REALITY OF THE WORLD THEY
WERE BORN INTO.
A NIGHTMARE THAT FOLLOWED THEM
THOUSANDS OF KILOMETERS FROM
THEIR HOMELAND IN XINJIANG.
SHE TELLS THEM, DADDY IS AWAY
WORKING.
THE LAST TIME SHE HEARD FROM HER
HUSBAND HE WAS BEING DETAINED IN
EGYPT IN JULY 2017.
>> HE SAID, YOU ARE MY -- MY
PRECIOUS.
I LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
AND FROM THAT DAY I DID NOT GET
ANY MESSAGE ABOUT HIM.
>> Reporter: MIRIAM WAS LIVING
HER DREAM.
THEY STUDIED IN CAIRO AT
UNIVERSITY, GOT MARRIED AND
STARTED A FAMILY.
WHEN CHINA'S LONG ARM REACHED
EGYPT, THEY SCRAMBLED TO GET
OUT.
SHE FLEW TO TURKEY WITH THE BOYS
AND WITH REPORTS OF ARRESTS AT
THE AIRPORT, HE TRIED TO GET THE
FERRY OUT TO JORDAN BUT WAS
STOPPED.
THERE WAS LITTLE MIRIAM COULD DO
TO TRY AND FIND HER HUSBAND.
SHE WROTE LETTERS TO U.N.
AGENCIES AND GOVERNMENTS, BUT
SHE SAYS NO ONE RESPONDED.
THE DETENTION WAS NEVER
ACKNOWLEDGED.
LIKE OTHERS, HE JUST VANISHED
WITHOUT A TRACE.
EGYPTIAN AUTHORITIES BELIEVED TO
BE ACTING AT THE BEHEST OF THE
GOVERNMENT ROUNDED UP DOZENS,
POSSIBLY HUNDREDS OF UIGHURS,
MANY OF THEM MALE STUDENTS.
MORE THAN 20 WERE FORCIBLY
RETURNED TO CHINA, ACCORDING TO
HUMAN RIGHTS GROUPS.
THE CHINESE CRACKDOWN ON UIGHURS
HAD EXPANDED FAR BEYOND ITS
BORDERS.
>> NOT AN EXACT NUMBER.
IT MAY BE MORE.
>> Reporter: A WUIGHUR ABLTH
VISIT HA
ACTIVIST HAS DOCUMENTED
DETENTIONS.
BUT THEY DON'T KNOW HOW MANY MAY
BE BEHIND BARS OR HOW MANY HAVE
BEEN DEPORTED BACK TO CHINA.
TOO OFTEN FAMILY MEMBERS FEAR
THAT GOING PUBLIC WOULD ONLY
MAKE THINGS WORSE FOR THEIR
DISAPPEARED LOVED ONES.
>> HE IS MY CHILDREN'S DAD.
>> Reporter: SHE IS TORMENTED BY
DEVASTATING GUILT.
DID SHE PUSH TOO MUCH?
DID SHE NOT DO ENOUGH TO TRY AND
SAVE HER HUSBAND?
SHE FEARS FAMILY IN CHINA WILL
PAY THE PRICE FOR HER SPEAKING
OUT NOW, BUT SHE SAYS VIOLENCE
IS NO LONGER AN OPTION.
>> IN TWO YEARS THIS KIND OF
GUILTY FEELING IS ALWAYS INSIDE
OF ME, AND I AM NOT ABLE TO
SLEEP.
NOT ABLE TO EVEN LIKE -- IF I
FEEL HAPPY, I HAVE NO RIGHT TO
FEELING HAPPY.
I HAVE NO RIGHT TO SMILE.
I'M LIVING LIKE THIS.
>> HER HUSBAND LIVED AND WORKED
IN THE UAE FOR TEN YEARS.
IN FEBRUARY 2018, HE WAS
DETAINED WHILE PICKING UP
PAPERWORK FROM A DUBAI POLICE
STATION.
IT WAS TWO WEEKS FROM HELL FOR A
NINE-MONTH PREGNANT AMANISA AND
HER SON.
CHASING AHMED AS HE WAS MOVED
BETWEEN POLICE STATIONS AND
JAILS.
>> I HAVE FEAR IF I DON'T HURRY
UP, MY HUSBAND WILL BE DEPORTED.
I'M REALLY WORRIED ABOUT HIM AT
THE TIME.
I FEEL EXTREMELY HELPLESS AND
THERE IS NO ONE CAN HELP ME AT
THIS TIME.
>> THIS IS THE DOCUMENT YOU GOT
FROM COURT?
>> YES.
>> SHE SAID NO ONE WOULD EVEN
TELL HER WHAT AHMED WAS ACCUSED
OF, ONLY THAT HE WAS WANTED BY
CHINA.
THIS DOCUMENT SHE OBTAINED FROM
THE DUBAI PUBLIC PROSECUTION
CONFIRMS THE CHINESE EXTRADITION
REQUEST.
IT ALSO STATES THE PROSECUTION
DECIDED TO CLOSE THE CASE
BECAUSE CHINESE AUTHORITIES
FAILED TO PROVIDE THE REQUIRED
DOCUMENTS.
BUT AHMED WAS TRANSFERRED TO ABU
DHABI AND SHE WAS TOLD HE WAS
SENT BACK TO CHINA.
>> MY HUSBAND HAVE ANY CRIME, IF
HE COMMITTED ANY CRIME, WHY THEY
DON'T TELL ME Y CHINA DON'T TELL
ME?
WHAT'S THE MOST DIFFICULT
QUESTION IN MY LIFE IS WHERE IS
MY DAD.
>> Reporter: 8-YEAR-OLD MUSA IS
LEFT WITH PHOTOS AND PATCHY
CHILDHOOD MEMORIES.
>> THIS WAS IN DUBAI?
>> YES.
WE'RE MAKING A CASTLE.
I CANNOT MAKE A CASTLE WITHOUT
MY DADDY.
>> Reporter: HE'S LUCKY HIS
LITTLE SISTER NEVER MET HER
FATHER.
LIKE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
UIGHURS, THE FAMILY FOUND
SANCTUARY IN TURKEY.
BUT AS THE GOVERNMENT FORGES
CLOSER TIES WITH CHINA, UIGHURS
FEEL THEIR SAFE SPACE IS
SHRINKING.
WITH NOWHERE LEFT TO TURN, SHE
SAYS SHE ONCE ASKED FOR
DIRECTIONS TO THE SEA.
>> I WANT TO TAKE MY CHILD.
I WANT TO SIT THERE.
ACTUALLY WHAT I WANT TO DO IS I
WANT TO GO INSIDE BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO SWIM.
>> Reporter: SHE ASKS, IS THIS
WORLD JUST NOT BIG ENOUGH FOR
UIGHURS?
>> A TRULY HEARTBREAKING REPORT
THERE.
YOU SAW THERE SHE SAID AS SHE'S
LIVING IN TURKEY NOW.
THAT'S WHERE WE FIND JOMANA WHO
JOINS US FROM ISTANBUL.
FIRST, LET'S START WITH THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT RESPONSE.
WHAT HAVE THEY SAID REGARDING
YOUR REPORTING?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, ISA, I
WANT TO ADD THAT HUMAN RIGHTS
WATCH SAYS THAT IT IS IMPOSSIBLE
IN MANY OF THESE CASES TO FIND
OUT WHAT HAPPENS TO THOSE
FORCIBLY RETURNED TO CHINA.
WE REACHED OUT TO THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT.
THEY DID NOT RESPOND TO OUR
REQUEST FOR COMMENT ON OUR
REPORTING.
BUT BEIJING HAS REPEATEDLY
DENIED ALLEGATIONS OF HUMAN
RIGHTS ABUSES TARGETING ITS
UIGHUR MINORITY AND ACCUSATIONS
OF GENOCIDE.
RECENTLY T